only fan counter
rose revenue 553
during pandemic and
that's 390 million dollars after
lockdown left consumers looking for
entertainment and out of work
performance looking for a place to
provide report to ft the london-based
platform offers sex workers fitness
influencers and celebrities like rapper
cardi b and avenue to connect directly
with the fans and get paid via
subscription services plus tips
its users base grew from uh less than 20
million to
120 million over 300 creators earned
more than a million dollars in 2020. wow
but only nsfw
mean
not safe in general not safe earlier uh
not safe for work earlier this year
subscribers faced backlash after rapper
bad bad b how do you say that say that
baby bad baby broke the only fan's
record by making a million dollars in
less than six hours after turning 18
only the week before so yeah that was
the whole creepy thing that that whole
thing with her danielle bregoli bad baby
like that's a weird thing where like
she's been hyper sexualized since she
was like 15 years old and there was like
a countdown for her to turn 18 and all
these other things man but that's a
whole different king caboodle uh you
know what you know what i like most
about the about porn pat
here we go is there a long list of
all right pbd podcast uh instagram queue
up your short clip the uh
not they they are the most innovative
digital marketplace in the world
everything in the digital marketplace
follows their lead and what you're
seeing here is the future of
entertainment you're seeing personalized
entertainment you're seeing access
people are literally they're not you can
get porn for free everywhere they're not
paying for the nudity they're paying for
the interaction they're paying for the
connection they're paying for the time
feeling special yes this is going this
right here mark my words this is the
future of
sports this is the future of the music
industry there's gonna be people who are
paying money to be in the dugout after a
strikeout with a guy you're gonna you're
there's gonna be a an ipad and i'm gonna
be able to curse off mike stan for
blowing uh my fantasy game or i'm going
to be able to be like mike stan here's
five grand i just i just won uh 10 grand
on on the game because that home run you
you hit just put just locked in the over
it's going to be one-on-one access it's
going to be real time i was on tour with
catfish cooley one of the coolest dudes
ever national headliner sells out rooms
theaters 500 seats 1200 seats his wife
has an only fans account she's very open
about it i'm not breaking any news here
she makes more money on only fans than
he does he's a national headline act
he's got three and a half million
followers
she makes more money on her only fans
than he makes as a national headliner so
the marketplace is there this is a proof
of concept for access for all
entertainment
uh they only fans said that they want to
get out of the the pornography game they
want to get out of the not safe for work
game i said okay yeah good luck with
that
let's just say they did that what would
happen say they did that
they lose 550 through 52 of their their
revenue you know i mean sex still sells
but um
listen i think it's been great for the
porn industry i think it's been great
for the porn industry i i used to do
comedy shows with with porn stars and
stuff that's why pat's always you know
joking like i did comedy shows with lisa
and these other these are decent human
beings man they're they're human beings
they're sex workers this is how they
they've all they've all had trauma in
their life they've overcome their trauma
we may not uh agree with their life
decisions but they're they're business
people they are entrepreneurs they're
hard workers and they're fun people man
and
this allows them an opportunity to work
to apply their craft in a safe
environment where they don't have to go
somewhere and you know be in an dude
look at porn the real problem with porn
is is the porn industry right less than
outside of the morals like everybody can
have their own you know views on the
morals the industry's scaly as hell this
allows these people to make incredible
amounts of money and avoid all of those
pitfalls now
you talked about this earlier and i'll
leave this up to you because i don't
have kids i i would be very very wary of
snapchat of only fans if i had a 16 17
or 18 year old daughter this would be
like something like that kept me up at
night i'd be like absolutely not let me
let me see your phone let me see your
accounts like you'd have to police the
hell out of that because the
temptation's just too great the
temptation is just there i mean like you
said this girl danielle bregoli made a
million dollars at 18 years old but
that's she that's who she is for the
rest of her life now right so i and not
not that there's anything wrong with
that but at the same time it's just like
i don't know like you're gonna want that
for your family you know we'll go have a
few years
um you know talk about a perfect storm i
don't think any company has benefited
more from the pandemic than
only fam or whatever this only fans yeah
because it's not a stock price like
tesla or zero
right
what is this again with the name of this
company um
it's subscribers this is a
subscription-based service and they're
growing and by the way
now we know why no one wants to go to
the office anymore right i mean here's
your answer right here because there's
no such thing as nsfw because nobody
goes to the office they're at home so
this is the perfect storm for them and
they've captured lightning in a bottle
and you know they're pretty smart about
how they do it because it's not complex
and they reward
the entertainers
it's eighty percent they keep eighty
percent brilliant business it's a twenty
percent digital model so this is a
company that did two billion in revenue
last year which if you think about the
second largest health club chain in the
country lifetime fitness that's about
what they do in revenue two billion you
know with 250 locations this is easily
scalable though this is a business model
that's scalable yeah of course um so 300
people became how many of the 300
millionaires are in the porn industry do
you think probably 95 of them no i don't
think so i think it's i think it's
probably going to be let's see
by the way let's let's let's know
i worked in chatsworth valleys for a
while chatsworth at one point eighty
percent of all the porn was produced in
chatsworth california
a lot of our members were porn stars
late at night when i would close this
yeah right by van nuys at midnight when
i would close the gym they would always
come and say hey you mind if we because
we were the only one that had an outdoor
pool it's like you mind if we just kick
it outside and i'm like listen guys kick
it fine anything like that you can't
because i'm going to get in trouble so i
would stay with them for an hour but the
life is not the just
we're not here glorifying the life the
life
that world to go into that world you
have to have a pretty rough life to want
to go into that world that's not there
is issues upbringing family parents
father mother there's a lot of issues
there before you get into it for every
one story it's like oh ever since i was
a kid i wanted to you don't hear those
steps no there's a few industries you
don't hear one you don't hear somebody
saying ever since i was a kid i wanted
to go into porn ever since i was a kid i
wanted to go into you know
this industry it happens because of
desperation many times and the money can
be good now uh uh drugs alcohol all of
that stuff diseases it's it's a it's a
messy industry to be a part of but it is
what it is and there's a market for it
right so uh
can they change their model and get away
with it no am i surprised that they grew
553 no uh could that have been a
thousand percent
yes 300 people making a million dollars
is that attractive to a lot of people
yes could this be a model that's going
to continue to grow for a long time to
come i don't think it's going to go well
let me let me ask you do you think
instagram would be where it is today if
it wasn't for girls with uh thongs
on taking pictures every day or you know
girls with with the stringiest of
bikinis that that doesn't seem to bother
people morally you're an influencer
you're a model but then if you just take
off that little piece of string now all
of a sudden you're immoral like i i i
have a tough time with with that like
you're an instagram model you're an
influencer calvin klein will give you
ten thousand dollars to do a spot right
chloe chloe jenner can do whatever she
wants and also i think kim kardashian
kind of changed all this stuff kim
kardashian did porn to get famous
she all but admits it now that that it
was the mother's idea to put out this
porn tape so that she was no longer
paris hilton's closet organizer now she
becomes this international brand and how
many other people have done the same
thing the teen mom this and that it was
like
porn was something that oh my god i
can't believe this happened with pamela
anderson and tommy lee now it's
something people do to like jump start
putting you on the map nuts it gets the
attention by the way they don't have an
app yet right so this is all just online
do you think if they get an app that
makes it you know grow man that's crazy
so
you're gonna be sitting on the subway in
new york and someone's got their phone
out with their only fans got to get it
in so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you